i believe that no fight in the history
of one piece has been discussed as
heatedly by fans as the battle between
luffy and katakuri during the climax of
the whole cake island arc
while on the surface it seemed to be
similar to the usual pattern that
luffy's battle followed throughout the
story this one felt oddly but pleasantly
different and i think many people
couldn't quite pinpoint what exactly it
was that made category so unique as a
major one-piece antagonist compared to
the likes of crocodile luci or doe
flamingo
when we first meet category in the story
he's introduced as a typical trope of
the cool calm and competent villain that
seems to be on top of things no matter
what
compared to most of his siblings he
stands out as someone who's actually
able to take action on his own and we
understand right from the get-go that
this is someone who's essential in
keeping the big mom pirates relevant as
a yonko crew functioning as the de facto
captain during big mom's rage combined
with his power as well as the deep care
he shows for his family he's one of the
most popular members of the crew in all
of whole cake islands
on top of all this katakuri also
introduces us to the concept of future
sites a very advanced form of ken buncho
kohaki that allows him to look several
seconds ahead into the future and react
accordingly a skill so rare that it's
not even shared by his mother big mom
and so overall when luffy manages to
pull category into a one versus one
fight in the mirror world to enable his
crew's escape naturally we all
anticipated this battle to be one of the
most challenging ones for luffy so far
against an antagonist that seems
extremely rational and calculated
and what follows is one of the best
battles and character arcs in the story
so far
[Music]
this is where the main theme of
category's character comes into play and
it's actually so important that it will
serve as the overarching framework for
this entire character analysis
mirrors
everything about category is reflected
in the symbol of the mirror on the
smallest level this can be seen in terms
of his future size that is all about
looking ahead and seeing things that you
usually can't just like you can use a
mirror to look around corners
and just like a mirror your future side
can be blurred when losing composure
but i honestly think it's so much more
interesting to look at this symbol on a
much larger scale because the main
implication here is that katakuri and
luffy mirror each other as characters on
more than just one level
to really understand to what extent oda
has created katakuri as a mirrored
version of luffy i think it's best to
peel away the layers one by one
on the most superficial level luffy and
category are similar simply based on the
devil food powers
while luffy is made of rubber katakuri
is made of mochi a malleable sort of
rice cake that can easily change its
shape
this is not the first time that oda has
shown us a villain with a similar power
to luffy's
thinking back to before the time skip
bellamy was also quite similar to
luffy's ability in terms of speed and
bounciness
the purpose of this trope is to have the
protagonist quote unquote fight and
overcome himself and thus give us an
idea where he stands in terms of his
power developments
in bellamy's case we saw that luffy was
actually way stronger than him which was
in line with his up and coming rookie
status before the alabasta arc
katakuri however shows us the exact
opposite
while his powers are even more similar
to luffy's his message at the beginning
of the fight is clear
whatever you can do with your devil
fruit i can do better and so we learn
very quickly that the underlying subtext
of this battle is for luffy to overcome
himself and increase his fighting
abilities
in other words this was the very first
battle where in line with rayleigh's
explanation on ruskina he will have to
become stronger during a battle compared
to training beforehand as he did for
instance against lucci
and what makes this battle against
category so unique from luffy's
perspective is the incentive for it
you see in almost every single major
battle luffy's victory ends in the
liberation of the people oppressed by
the villain as he's fighting for their
sake in the first place
luffy defeating arlung for instance
meant freeing nami and her village from
his oppression
taking out crocodile meant the end of
the civil war and suffering in alabasta
and when luffy punched doflamingo down
into the ground it literally cut the
strings that were controlling dressrosa
it's this pattern that usually makes his
fight so satisfying to see
against katakuri however luffy doesn't
free whole cake island or the big mom
pirates from the yonkos rage and tyranny
[Music]
beating katakuri wouldn't change the
country itself
and since luffy has already retrieved
sanji and protected his crew by shutting
himself together with katakuri in the
mirror worlds there was no one to
liberate or rescue and so suddenly his
battle and relationship with katakuri
moved to a much more personal level that
was all about power and ideology and for
the very first time he was able to fully
focus on himself and his own ambitions
this is i think what makes katakuri so
different and unique in the story
[Music]
so here we have the main objective for
luffy however moving down yet another
layer luffy and katakuri mirror each
other not only on a physical level but
on a personal level as well
[Music]
and this is where we get to the really
interesting part of this video
as we slowly learn over the course of
their fight katakuri's cool and composed
demeanor starts to crack and slowly fall
apart
both him and luffy have crazily similar
personalities only that katakuri has
built up this false persona over time in
hope to protect his family
in his flashback we see a happy and
careless boy that is unapologetic about
who he is
when perospero tells him that his life
would be much easier if he simply
covered up his mouth katakuri answers
that he doesn't care what others think
about him and that he would simply beat
up anyone if necessary
[Music]
the second trait we notice about him is
his strong protective nature when it
comes to his family
this strongly reminds us of the luffy
that we know today and so he only adopts
his quote-unquote perfect persona once
brulee gets attacked because of him
he lost his true self to the desire to
protect his family we actually saw a
similar moment in luffy's life after
aces death where he lost faith in
himself
luckily however he had jinbe in that
moment to set him straight
unfortunately for katakuri though he
didn't have someone like that within the
ranks of his big but quite unloving
family
therefore he adopted this new persona to
protect his loved ones and we can also
see this discrepancy really well during
the merienda scene
[Music]
while luffy doesn't care looking weak in
front of his friends as we see in his
encounter with sanji earlier in this arc
nor about showing happiness and
enjoyment katakuri literally puts walls
around him to keep anyone from seeing
his love for lying down and eating
donuts
luffy has to break down those literal
walls for him to wake him up to the
loneliness he's in
despite being a well-respected member of
the biggest family in the world
nobody understands him and knows who he
really is at heart
and so i believe what really sparked
category's interest and initial anger
when facing off against luffy was the
fact that he saw himself and his lost
potential reflected in him and so he had
to prove to himself that he made the
right decision in hiding his true self
and covering up his face
thus at the beginning of the fight the
emphasis wasn't so much on i'm stronger
than you
but rather on everything you do i do
better
i believe that the excuse that luffy
will become a danger to big mom that
needs to be eliminated right away was
only part of his motivation
and so the fight became much more
personal for category as well
as a result we have a battle between two
people who are incredibly involved with
each other one fighting to reach his
potential in terms of power and the
other in terms of character
and i think that the resilience and will
that luffy demonstrates to ultimately
beat category are also wonderfully
reflected by the similar devil fruit
powers as well
while katakuri is mochi that when
pounded stays pretty much as it is luffy
being rubber always bounces back and
can't be squashed
this fantastic thematic concept combined
with a compelling multi-layered
personality
is what gives katakuri's character this
intimate and likable feel that is quite
unique in the story so far
both luffy and katakuri make the other
reflect on themselves and their
respective weaknesses
as a result the battle is one of the
best sequences of character crafting and
character development at the same time
mixing great physical growth on luffy's
part with great psychological growth on
categories
as their fight progresses katakuri gains
more and more respect for luffy
this is evident in the shift of language
used as karakori now is saying things
like
[Music]
[Music]
and so he slowly starts to admire
luffy's resilience and a rapid
development of his future side skills
it reaches a point where both are
fighting at full strength but both also
seem to be really enjoying their duel
this becomes especially clear in the
iconic scene where katakuri stabs
himself to make up for the wound he
inflicted to luffy after flampay's
interference
the fact that both of them take her and
the other onlookers out of the picture
with their congress hockey makes the
relationship between the two even better
in my opinion
at this point luffy has fully convinced
category that being yourself and living
authentically is important
not only for your own happiness and
growth but also for that of the people
around you
better to be understood and accepted by
few like brulee
rather than being admired for pretending
to be someone else by someone like
flampay
[Music]
katakuri throws up his scarf and starts
embracing his true self once again and
so while both fight at full strength his
motive has completely changed at this
point katakuri has a direct interest in
luffy actually winning this fight and
proving to him that being yourself is
the right way to go
in a way luffy defeating him would set
him free from the facade that he's built
for himself
[Music]
and so while i believe that luffy fairly
beat category in terms of power and
strength he made it a point to fall on
his back showing luffy his respect for
his growth while at the same time
breaking the biggest aspect of his old
fake persona
now his character has changed completely
from the cold and calculated villain to
a compassionate and honorable antagonist
that has now developed a true liking
towards luffy
and so bringing all of this back to what
we talked about earlier what makes this
fight so different is that luffy is not
liberating someone from the antagonist
but in this case liberates the
antagonist himself
all of this culminates in the
heartwarming scene after the end of
their fight as brulee tends to her
brother's wounds
she knew perfectly well that katakuri
had fallen willingly on his back and
when katakuri asks about luffy brulee
guesses that he would be pleased to know
that luffy has successfully escaped
toddling
katakuri smirks confirming her
assumption and so in the end it was only
brule out of all people who was the only
one to care the most for her brother's
true self and suffering
and bringing this entire theme full
circle it was her that with her mirror
powers enabled his and luffy's change in
the first place
[Music]
as a result i think it's more than fair
to argue that while luffy won the
overall battle katakuri went out of this
fight as a true winner himself having
regained his sense of who he is and
being pulled from his loneliness and
isolation
it sets him up to become relevant once
again in the story and makes him one of
my favorite antagonists in all of one
piece